his nation, but for all the nations.
And
he referred to this as a shafa.
What UT to shafa.
In the narration of Jabir, I've been
given five things that no other prophet
before me has been given. And he
referred to this as what UT to shafa.
And so the people will be waiting on
the day of judgement. We all will be
waiting on the day of judgement for
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to come and
judge and commence judgement.
And
people will be in a state of extreme
anxiety, extreme
extremely apprehensive. And so they will
decide to look for the most virtuous
of people to intercede for them. To
intercede for them
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commence
his judgement. And so they will go to
Adam.
And he will refer them to
Nuh. And Nuh will refer them to
Ibrahim alayhis salaam. And we stop
there. So when they come to Ibrahim
alayhis salaam,
he will say to them inna rabbi
Nafsi nafsi nafsi.
And so Ibrahim alayhis salaam will say
today my lord has become angry with an
anger that he has not
had before this and he will not have
again after.
And indeed, I told three
mis truths.
And he refers to them as kidhbet,
which is plural for kidhba. And a kidhba
in the language of the prophet salallahu
alayhi wasallam is any
statement or any notion that the
listener is given
that
does not coincide with
the
reality
that they are inquiring about. Those
parameters are very important because
when we look at these three kidhbet
that Ibrahim alayhi salaam told, we see
that they're not lies in the sense that
we understand what a lie is. Something
is yes and he said no. Something is
there and he said it's not there.
Something is not there and he said it's
there. This is not the kind of lies that
he was speaking about. These mis truths
or if you will, misdirections,
they are referred to by the scholars of
Islam as a tawriya. And a tawriya
essentially is that a person says
something that is true, just not true in
the context that the listener is
expecting.
It's true, but not true in the context
that the listener
is expecting.
In another wording of this same
narration, the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam clearly says what these three
are.
He said in that
Ibrahim alayhi salaam
kadh kadhaba thalatha kidhbat.
Ithnani
[Arabic recitation]
Alaihis Salaam did give three instances
of misdirection.
two of them for the sake of Allah and
one of them with respect to his wife
Sarah.
So the two
that he mentions for the sake of Allah
was in his debate with his people.
And that is that
he said when they told him to come with
them in the second.
I'm I am sick and he meant it in that he
is spiritually sick. He is sickened by
their
worship of other than Allah.
But they understood it to mean
physically sick.
Right? So it's true. It's just not true
in the context that the listener is
expecting.
The second is that he destroyed the
idols and he left the biggest one.
And then when they asked him
The ask the big one. He
you know, he's got the ax there. Looks
he did it. Ask him.
The big one did it.
Now notice
they all know that this is a type of
sarcasm.
Right?
So the listener
it is not true in itself, but the
listener knows that it's not true.
some scholars counted
the debate that he had with his people
that is mentioned in Surat Al-An'am.
[Arabic recitation]
that these are the two. And then the
third one is that when a Namrood took
him and wanted to take his wife, he said
to his wife, "Say that I'm your
brother." Right? So that they wouldn't
kill him.
And so,
what did he mean? He is her brother in
Islam.
In Islam.
Right? But they the listener understands
it to be her brother in blood, in
relation.
So it's true, just not in the same
context. We gave another example of this
of the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam in the battle of Badr.
So, Badr was not supposed to be a
battle.
It wasn't.
Badr was supposed to just be a
caravan
that they got word
was coming back from Ash-Sham. Remember
Ash-Sham, Allah says the Shita'i was
safe. So this caravan was coming back.
Abu Sufyan was leading this caravan. It
had about 40 men guarding it. You know,
light work, just enough to be able to
fend off bandits, you know.
That's that's what a caravan is. They're
not They're not dressed for war. Right?
Imagine a soldier in our day versus a
Brinks truck, you know, an armored
truck. They're not dressed for war.
They don't have weapons for war. They
They have civilian level weapons. And
so, this is what they were expecting.
So, based on that into
intelligence
they had far more than they needed
with respect to manpower. He took 315
or 313
different narrations, only one horseman.
Right?
That's all that he needed.
And they had light
weapons, light armor. They weren't going
expecting a war. They were going
expecting
a caravan.
But then, that information got leaked.
And Abu Sufyan took a different route
and sent
you know, someone to Mecca.
And they prepared an army and they
mobilized very quickly. So, by the time
they arrived at Badr, the caravan was
gone and the army was on its way.
And so, when he realized that the
caravan is not there, something is
wrong. This is the path that they're
supposed to be taking.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
and his companions, they surmised
that they got wind that we were coming.
And this is not something you could just
turn away and go back home. Right? When
you have a an army that you're facing,
if you turn away and go back home,
they'd just follow you. Right? So,
the problem was that they were stuck.
And so
there was, you know, another caravan or
some travelers on the road coming from
that direction. And the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam was asking
them
did you see an army mobilize coming
this way?
And it was a big army because they had
over a thousand combatants with them.
And they came with big
with big weapons, right? They came fully
armored. Some of them had armor from his
head all the way to his toes. The only
thing showing was his eyes.
That's
war. They came intending war, right? So,
he asked this
travelers
and they said, "Well, tell us where
you're from."
Well, he didn't want to say, "We're from
Medina. We are the Muslimin." Right?
I'm Muhammad ibn Abdillah, the messenger
of Allah. This is Abu Bakr and this is
Omar and my social security and my
address. They didn't want to say that
because this will get back to the other
army.
So, he said, "Well, tell us if you saw
and I'll tell you where we're from if
you tell us."
Now, the word from in Arabic is
min ma.
Ma here could mean what are you from and
it could mean where are you from. It's
ambiguous in Arabic. In English, it's
not, but in Arabic, it is.
And so, he said, "Yes, we saw them
coming." He said, "How many camels are
they slaughtering?" He said, "They're
slaughtering 10."
10 camels. He figured it was roughly a
thousand men that were coming. And so,
he turned to leave and they said, "Wait.
You said you'd tell us
who you are." He said, "Nahnu min ma."
Nahnu min ma.
Which translates to we're from water.
From water, meaning Allah created us
from water. They understood it to mean
some obscure village in Iraq. That's
what they thought. Right? So, this is an
example of tawriya. Now, in the Arabic
language, in the language of Quraysh,
you would refer to this misdirection as
kadhib.
Because it's not
exactly what the listener was expecting
to hear. That's the wrong context, even
if it's right in another context. It's a
misdirection.
And so, Ibrahim says, "Okay, inni
kadhabtu thalath kidhbat." Now, for a
regular Muslim, a regular person, is
this haram?
Well, the scholars differ on this. The
majority of the scholars say
misdirection is only haram if you are to
swear on it.
If you're taking an oath,
or
or you are
testifying as a witness,
then it is categorically haram
to use misdirection, tawriya.
However, outside of that,
it is makruh. It is disliked that a
person practices this for a number of
reasons.
and
that is for us, but for a messenger, for
a prophet of Allah, no. This is not
something that is necessarily
acceptable. It's not really becoming.
And so, that's the reason that Ibrahim
mentions it here and counts it as one of
his mistakes. And so, Ibrahim alayhis
salaam says, "Wa inni kuntu kadhabtu
thalatha kadhabat. Nafsi nafsi nafsi.
Idhhabu ila ghayri. Idhhabu ila Musa."
So, he will say, "I am worried about
myself right now. I am focused on my own
self.
I can't take on anyone else's anxiety or
problems."
And so, he will say, "Go to someone
else, go to Musa.
Right? Go to Musa. So we will stop there
and continue this
tomorrow
Saturday night or tomorrow night in sha
Allah. As-salamu alaykum
and you are welcome and may Allah
be with
you and
may Allah
be with you and may Allah be with you
and may Allah be with you and may Allah
be with you and may Allah